efectivamente un informe abrumador que
reveló la magnitud del fenómeno de la
penalidad en la iglesia francesa con
cifras con cifras absolutamente
sorprendentes desde los años 50 330 mil
víctimas de la iglesia entre ellas 216
mil personas abusadas sexualmente por
religiosos este tema fue evocado durante
el encuentro entre entre los dos hombres
ron castex compartió con la prensa al
final del encuentro algunas de las
palabras que les dije que le dijo el
papá quien dice que confía en la iglesia
francesa para encontrar una solución a
este grave problema el tema del secreto
de la confesión también fue evocado
castex dijo que se siente claramente que
la iglesia no va a reconsiderar este
dogma pero que el papá francisco está de
acuerdo con la necesidad de encontrar
mecanismos para adaptar este secreto a
el derecho penal y al derecho de las
víctimas otros temas también fueron
evocados dura entre ellos la situación
en él no en irak y también el
calentamiento global